hey what we're doing for dinner I don't
matter matter pizza yeah you want to get
some oh wait I didn't meet you guys
still here Oh walkers oh it's gone all
right this is not gonna go well because
I'm gonna do Meatwad voices Rick Wow I
should do butters Laurie that would be
don't be a good start for Carl oh no no
what about now nope not butters oh oh oh
her bottle looks a little little bill
can you shut up for two seconds this is
not gonna go well
all right whatever you know what we're
gonna start we're doing this it's going
it's going guys
we're playing you think we're losing the
walking dead but we're not whoa we're
all walking de-ball we're not this is
not gonna go well
an old murdered willed you get low more
armor down don't ask questions you don't
want the answer to
cuz apparently you got it too boo boo
boo boo boo baby just go ahh my name's
Arthur this is my form we needed to flee
as we were run over by walkers
oh you got me careful the walkers enjoy
the bar well then they're more than one
occasion stay River we leave you covered
don't waste time head for the path in
the front of the yard there me Oh God
either some banging gonna Walker's in
the door there's Walker roof do I want
to do I'm on the toilet why there's
paper there's toilet paper
where are you upstairs upstairs leaking
upstairs my ones are just changed into
an X you think is the x-blade a we're
upstairs I'll ask a girl I'm upstairs go
left into the bath I'm an assassin
I'm in a better chance oh my god oh my
god Walker's in the bathroom help
Oh we list
we lost Billy Bob Joe Oh Bob Bob you're
looking yeah we like Gary
now who y'all everyone sleep with yo Bob
come here
why look read that free wad look at ya
yeah what it says doll I mean the office
yes there's chests in the office there's
a zombie pigman oh my god I'm the
weakest person ever I must be Laurie oh
my god hey Laurie's emotionally strong
there's on everybody
oh she gets to have all the sex you want
oh god everybody you know what look
we're gonna start over I'll do this
Orica dope yep we're gonna say this is
not gonna go well this is it this is the
episode hello everybody
ah my eyes barbed wire a welcome jungle
you better start this from the beginning
this is more or I'm not markiplier
that's fire
I'm Way too wait a minute you're way too
dick I'm wait a minute oh no I thought I
got walked okay okay all right okay all
right okay all right all right all right
all right all right
not ready I'm ready right let's go cuz
you think we're safe but we ain't Rick
where am i ashamed no wait I'm Rick if I
said that I forgot I think you know who
you are but you don't mask you cover
wait you asked me instead back you come
easy we're navy rehearsals farm cuz we
ate wait outside on the roof but now I'm
on the outside
Oh Random House alright I just went into
a lab oh I am outside a lab I didn't
know Herschel had a lab however my my
well good the drug my crafts I will read
these guys I can't read it it's dark we
already did this my name is Urgell and
welcome to my storm
enjoyable activities there's a way we
thank you have a good time
I'm Hershel Shane I need food Rick who
wait is Rick Rick Rick Rick what's today
with Asia kid uh when Glen and good and
Bob lets off Bob is Lori let's go let's
go let's go good think you're ready to
go but I'm dead this is the worst this
is the worst episode we've ever made we
only started it twice now is the worst
it can't get no you know it all right
we're good I'm done trying to fix it
this is just yo mark nice no say you
start from our original starting point
let's just go and we'll go okay why is
the front door open I don't know I don't
know like basil or art come up here
there's a there's a pickaxe for you I
think you got beaten in I'm pretty sure
it got bashed in
I wanna bag a robbery well but there was
a hint saying she probably here to go
anywhere and grab the the lip pickaxe
from that Litella picky can break live
locks okay I fed do what the mob
spawners
oh uh can't be playing can't be playing
what there's real music that plays but
you probably can't have that on your
channel oh let's just go we're going out
we need to go explore the farm okay
don't legit we're going outside
thank you for letting us in your hands
up baby zombie I killed it it's adorable
it was adorable I don't even have a
sword all right let's go out all right
I'm the only one to legally squid real
you better watch Carl I won't watch Carl
I'll watch Lori I'll call him Lord need
to be really Laurie a - meaning are you
Laurie is that theirs is humble in the
well you hear that Rick me and Laurie
are having a real good time there's a
sign here that says I don't know I'm
done listening to you
sign here that says licious net there's
a Samba in the well there's a zato she
is oh I get it
oh my god ah Shane is now dead I'm
helped in Lua I've had lehel stayin
single I'm Mack Laurie oh gee how me
accident gonna drown oh you see how me
Shane is here to protect Laurie Rick you
think you deserve Laurie but you don't I
just picked up a bunch of stuff would
whoa okay I'm sorry
Oh kill zombies
I'm going in the whale I mean walkers
Walker oh my god there's something the
wire head hey there's a chest out here
but there's nothing in the whale I
opened it Oh
Farge you so hard a drown trying to get
back out I'm gay I'll go girl
ha ha ha one of the mega I'm gonna biker
I'm Jimmy
oh oh no don't don't go down there Bob
don't you guys go to the barn yet no no
we need to go to the barn I'm over at
the barn waiting for you Shane rig
Hershel I gotta finish round know that I
did not do that I didn't do that why
can't I get out get out
Laurie no oh it's just like season 7
where she drowns yeah Oh dad I might
need to be bleeped
there's no season 7 yeah but now they
know she two rounds oh yeah
wait I thought we were going to the barn
but you guys ran forward I'm going to
the bar and where's the barn back it's
by the house why is it back by I was
going on the path are you sad dog is
this perhaps Chris where's logs over
here oh stop fighting whatever here Oh
trust me I'm your husband about Carl I
am that's why we're going to the barn
where is Carl in the bar Carl's dead is
he in the house where he's supposed to
be Carl stay the house hey it's a barn
oh no it's a shovel Walker oh no it's
too shiny Walker's oh no not those
dreaded shovel walkers why are the why
are their shovel walkers how is that a
thing ah ok you know what let's just go
with the barn I'm in the bar I'm not I'm
gonna die don't
dah Laurie I love you seriously what is
that growling noise the mob spawner
what is it really what is the growling
where was the farm you what weren't you
just here up Oh uncle uncle uncle what
is it over here is this the barn I don't
know it's been a round the barn is the
big barn looking things in the middle of
an open field surrounded by walkers yeah
yes
partially I don't know why there's so
many walkers around Rick you would blame
me Shane but you are Rick no I'm [ __ ]
I've been shamed the whole time I
thought you were Shane I was what who
are you talking to wait is someone
invisible I don't know is there a ghast
is it zombie mmm god there's so many
walkers barn burns in the TV show lol
run boy what happened excuse me I just
read aside on the second floor of the
barn what what I shouldn't go into the
barn and should push some sort of button
Rick
I opened a chest Rick did you are you
trying to sabotage us Rick I wouldn't do
that okay III I can't I why can't you
open the chest a key the barns on fire
there's Walker's there are so many
walkers in there are no I'll an away why
is this a thing well I just found Sol
Sol Sol Fox Sofia spoilers I'm going to
die apparently this is how I die wait
why am i back in the barn
I think we're meant to die in a fiery
blaze in the barn
really I don't know Anakin Skywalker
that's not what happened to him hahaha
well wait hahaha I appreciate your
poignant references
I avoided your candor but you're not
even close you're kind of super I'm on a
birdie oh my god why are they so fast
I don't know long they're like Lauren is
on fire something has gone horribly
wrong
this is Jala flaming hahahaha you mean a
job job Oh a job job oh this is why we
fight entire first two seasons
why don't we fight the third season
there Rick because we leave Lori and get
together ourselves and have adopted
children haha oh yeah I forgot about
that
oh yeah what well do you all need
anything equipment-wise
ah your back sister can we stop the
zombies for like two seconds Kukui
please no more zombies a little bit want
Easter Bunny just calm down here huh
already everything needs to stop cuz
this is too much everything needs to
really stop okay down now alright why do
I have to horse so what's happening we
are we are and what we're doing is
trying to reenact the Walking Dead when
you do back to the beginning the Hulbert
I'm starting over again no no not let
the beginning of the episode not the
beginning episode you need to go back to
the beginning of the series where Rick
serious doesn't start in a farm no III
know this I know this boy just true the
sake of this thing we're doing here need
to back it up a bit okay
there's LLG crazy all right everybody
calm everybody relaxed
all right Oh get it no he's got it he
says he's got a walker head oh all right
so okay ow oh I'm calm
ha ha now in the beginning of The
Walking Dead Rick wakes up in a hostel
mm-hmm
Rick wake up in a hospital oh where am I
why are there IVs in my snowsuit or my
really there's IVs in your snausages
don't continue I like where this is
going go ahead where's Lori I need to
get these here snausages removed I'm not
there uh no ha ha ha wait oh my god Lori
come here with me yeah we're in the
woods remember we're in the woods okay
come here it's like I'm gonna throw some
bottles of Oh chanting at my feet right
here right here in the mud Lori Rick's
not here to anymore stop for you to move
on let's let's bang with unprotected sex
achill x' and make a baby I don't know
oh I know this right now brah I'm not
even actually we're all God Rick why we
are you were dad life we thought you
were dead
yeah I appreciate you saving Lori like
that I saw the CPR in the distance yeah
you're you're welcome I'm completely
oblivious for another few episodes i i i
comfortable with this role play anymore
ha ha ha don't worry Lauren oh how will
I ever choose I choose Rick ah I'm gonna
run off into the woods all Angry style
but I threw my pants I think
there's my pants
hahahahaha here's your pants back hey
here's your pants back about it oh okay
oh it's getting dark Shane what did I do
Rick I think I've done goofed we need to
work together we need to prepare but
prepare to protect cut oh my god
yeah everywhere guys there's a problem
there's Walker's afoot
there's walkers a hand to handling the
situation by killing me did I kill you
I'm back a few near Devils ideas only
makes good it's a baby zombie I wish I a
sorcerer's little arrow I just think I
just got a diamond sward of smiting i
man through the temple of Oh brah brah
I'm gonna die oh my god I'm gonna die
I'm gonna save you Laura
no no hey guys there's some golden
carrots
oh hey hey crap look I Barney Laura your
magical thank you I know Laura isn't
shaves off oh no I stop Laura died reg
you brought this of all dead tune huh
where where where why are no very solid
dream sequence Wow I'm gonna die without
your back Shane you kill me it's so many
you killed me
you're skipping ahead haha hey spoilers
yikes
god damn this is actually really bad
sister you should know that it was a
title Walking Dead there's gonna be
spoiler
we're like eight seasons in I mean come
on
haha the camera would be spoilers for
last season why Shane huh
I'm trying to save you Laurie behind
four times so far oh my god it's so dope
I think they always delusion is total
apocalypse
I found big richest chain see see my
glory
Laurie follow the path follow your heart
and the path but we went the wrong
direction our first mission was
backwards ha ha ha what mere kid turn
around Shane [ __ ] dude pick this up
whooshing where did you get this in the
book of love with Rory vision is off to
the path to the left there will you find
a man a man who I think his name is
Hershel about that I know but I'm
guessing my name's hurt oh here's the
left oh good it's quieted down a bit
this way first
Oh this wafer hurry
Watson [ __ ] I don't know where you
are
we went left of the fountain I'm in the
middle of the woods I keep dying and
respawning in the middle of nowhere why
protect coral and make the food Carl
King the house and damn it I don't know
where I go get away from what I'm not
I'm not
who's omble excuse me Hey look it's a
job job oh wait you're not a zombie you
just shot our friend Laurie I'm all
right
I didn't do it wait whoa whoa Wow I
would trade me from food for some weapon
how do we get in the basement oh here's
the basement all right
I'm going down okay I'm behind you
Laurie just like her and wait continue
that thought please keep talking please
just like the way it used to be oh I got
it
hi yesterday it's yeah what are the
buckets for the quarter hotter oh no I
just get on from I just held my chest
can't see anything
oh my god
there are walkers in here doing stuff to
me killing me stuff I don't know what's
happening Wow
hi I can't open that there's nothing in
there I know I don't think this is going
well
I think I'm hosed I think I think this
basement was a hoax guys get up to the
first floor please please okay now what
we're gonna do is we're gonna go back to
the beginning I'm stuck in a way we're
gonna start this episode over no cuz
it's gone wrong this is an episode all
in itself I don't know what why did Bob
hit me it said delicious why does that
it happen
oh no I threw out my brains away Oh God
zombie blow this up oh wait wait wait I
just got out he's love Islam
blow it all up no I'll be blowing up
this is the best time I've ever had it
up whoa blow it up blow it up quiet
Rick Shane hey let's let's take a sip of
our water
I just poured I just poured my drink all
over myself is why we say half-mast
Oh JA that was the worst episode ever
I don't know we've done some were [ __ ]
than that let's swear you guys it's that
it's that shots that you do at the first
episode like I I never seen you guys
struggle so hard to finish episodes oh
that was bad those so bad that wasn't
even a little bit funny there was you a
little bit uh we're still recording yeah
I know keep recording I need to like
compose bias now I can happen why had so
many good one liners though